what's going on guys this is Rob I have
a cold so you're gonna have to bear with
me but we are back with Ghost Rider now
we're gonna get the most powerful Ghost
Rider that you've ever seen at the end
of this comic and it is amazing so what
this does is this initially picks up in
the aftermath of the fight between Ghost
Rider and Wolverine you'll always find
that video down in the description but
basically some poor guy at the bar his
legs were chopped off and so he ends up
being possessed by a demon and he goes
forward as a new villain called exhaust
it's not really important pops up here
and there but you don't need to worry
about him too much the big caveat to all
this is that Johnny Blaze is finally
caught up to by Talia Warroad now
remember Talia War Road is basically
working with the FBI and that's one of
the things to know about the Ghost Rider
comics that in a lot of ways they're
kind of in their own world right Ghost
Rider doctor strange things like that
the magic and Mystic part of Marvel is
just kind of his own little world over
there but Talia Warroad has been
tracking Johnny Blaze down to try to
understand why all this crazy demonic
stuff has been taking place across the
world now we as the reader know that
everything's kind of gone into chaos
because the demons got a hold of Johnny
Blaze and basically kept the Ghost Rider
at Bay meaning that the Ghost Rider
never manifested which allowed all these
demons just kind of permeate the country
and do pretty much whatever they wanted
to do but now that Wolverine cut the
demon out of Johnny Blaze's head in one
of the most gruesome displays ever the
Ghost Riders back in full form and he is
literally on a war path
and so once Talia Warroad starts to
realize what's going on she comes to the
realization that the person that's
seemingly behind this giant
orchestration of events right where all
these demons are popping up is
Blackheart right now Blackheart is
basically the son of Mephisto in Marvel
Comics what's so funny about this is
that Mephisto is always off doing his
own thing and by and large doesn't
really care about what it is that
Blackheart does mostly because if things
get too far off track Mephisto can just
snatch him back to his own realm and
effectively call it a day but once
Johnny Blaze wakes up and he realizes
that tally is there her question for him
is do you want to help the FBI now there
reality about all this is that they're
operating under the radar right like the
FBI does not know that Talia is working
with Ghost Rider who's the very person
she's supposed to be going after but
once she starts to realize there's a
much bigger game afoot than simply just
Ghost Rider running around doing stuff
it's one of those things where it's I
need to Ally myself with this guy in
order to save the day otherwise it's
going to be game over for basically
everybody now here's where things get a
little bit murky because while that's
going on we're still dealing with the
death of alabaster and basically Zep now
for those of you guys who don't know who
they are that's fine we don't really
know either they were introduced
relatively recently in Marvel Comics
they're part of the Council of night
magicians they're super ambiguous we
know nothing about these guys so we're
kind of learning about them as we go
through so I'm sorry I can't really
provide you any answers there because
there are none now eventually Talia and
Johnny Blaze end up reaching their
destination which is Chicago and as soon
as they get there the Ghost Rider starts
freaking out it doesn't immediately take
over but one of the things we remember
is that Johnny Blaze has been
disconnected with the Ghost Rider for so
long with the two of them being
reconnected again there's still a kind
of Harmony that has to be achieved there
in the sense that the Ghost Rider is
almost kind of like a demonic barometer
right so whenever there's just like
demons within a reasonable vicinity the
Ghost Rider will basically start to
manifest kind of alerting Johnny Blaze
to what's going on and then punishment
ensues and then the Ghost Rider goes
away and Johnny Blaze comes back and
that's usually it but with Johnny Blaze
somewhat being out of phase with the
Ghost Rider while it doesn't full on
manifest it does allow him to see what
is basically the spiritual World things
that he wouldn't normally be able to see
with his own eyes the other part of this
is he says this place right Chicago this
place is sick which we know right
because it's Chicago a perfect example
of this is that they basically make
their way towards a church because as
the Ghost Rider starts to manifest and
things start to pop off that Talia tries
to reason with it and for the most part
she's successful which is actually kind
of an achievement in an event self
anybody who knows anything about the
Ghost Rider in Marvel Comics knows when
the Ghost Rider manifests and comes for
you there's no bargaining with this
thing right you get the Penance there
you get to be tortured and then your
soul gets sent to hell and that's
basically it right there's no bargaining
with this guy but Talia actually makes
this great case where she says I get
that you're here because of sins and
Punishment and all that kind of stuff
but there's something much bigger going
on here let me work with Johnny and we
will get this problem solved and we will
send you after whoever it is and you can
have all the punishment and all that
kind of stuff that you want and the
Ghost Rider ultimately just kind of
recedes and lets Johnny Blaze come back
it agrees with Talia Warroad unless the
two of them continue on but this whole
thing brings them to a church which
really makes you ask the question what
could possibly be going on in a place of
worship that the Ghost Rider would
manifest
outside of the fact that like there's so
much sin right it's the Catholic church
so I guess it makes perfect sense but
the thing here is once they get inside
this place is a massive occur people
have just been sacrificed inside this
place I mean it's gruesome so no wonder
the Ghost Rider LED them here because it
really is just all demons who are
engaging in all this stuff and so as
they make their way down into the
catacombs of this building there's just
like this crazed homeless man who keeps
babbling on about how they have to pay
and then he dumps out a cup full of
teeth and starts swatting at him with a
knife right so pretty typical for an
evening in Chicago but they end up
basically overcoming this guy and then
like he gets hit by a subway train but
when they see this train what they
realize is the train is filled with
people right like all throughout the
city of Chicago folks have just come up
missing and there really isn't any Rhyme
or Reason right it's not as though it's
only vagrants who have been taken right
homeless people that is basically people
from all walks of life the ultra Rich
the guy who's a single father of four
right just all kinds of things all kinds
of folks and so when this happens the
Ghost Rider manifest throws his chain
onto the subway train and hitches a ride
now what you're going to see here in a
second is going to be one of the most
epic things ever that I think I've ever
seen in a Ghost Rider comic because it's
pretty dope now exhaust shows up and
then he basically kind of torments
totally a war Road for a little bit
we'll talk about them here in a minute
because it's not really important right
now what is important is once the subway
train gets to his final destination you
basically have all these demons here who
are just feeding on people quite
literally right like just eating these
folks and that's the thing to understand
about what's going on in the Ghost Rider
comics right now that with the Ghost
Rider being gone and effectively never
dealing with any demons who had escaped
hell there was no one to keep this kind
of thing from happening but demons
operate underground they operate under
the radar so that nobody is the wiser to
the fact that they exist and by people
just kind of going missing casually and
back roads and things like that there's
no reason for The Avengers to get
involved the X-Men wouldn't care because
it's not mutants who are being attacked
so that would basically be it it all
comes down to the Ghost Rider to figure
it out and so this dude just this comes
riding up on the scene and it's not just
like Ghost Rider with like a flaming
chain it's Ghost Rider with a flaming
chainsaw right and literally just starts
attacking all these guys and then he
takes the chainsaw he attaches it to his
chain so he's literally got this flaming
chainsaw and he's just spinning it
around and circles over his head it's
one of the most epic things that I think
I've ever seen it's so cool it's one of
the reasons why I love the current Ghost
Rider run because it's a return to form
so like the old Ghost Rider stories but
some of these demons decide they want to
take a shot at the champ right come
running up on this guy and he helps them
finish with all their living and that's
basically it I mean just spinning a
chainsaw there's flaming around his head
right I mean you think you know just
Ward people off and make them believe
they don't want to have anything to do
with anything but the bigger part of
what's going on here this is what's so
cool what's really big about what's
going on here is the full on scheme that
Blackheart has one of the things to know
is that blackheart's motivations are not
that dissimilar from Mephisto Mephisto
is a ridiculously powerful being in
Marvel Comics he is almost unrivaled in
his own realm to the point that you'd be
a fool regardless of your power level
minus Franklin Richards to show up there
and try to fight him within the realm of
hell but the idea behind me fist though
is he always makes Bargains with people
there's always a catch but whenever you
make a bargain with Mephisto once that
bargain is satisfied your soul Goes to
Hell a good example of this is Dr Doom's
mom Blackheart is not that dissimilar
but what he's been doing here is his
mindset is basically nafiso can have
hell he can have hell all you know for
however long he wants that's his thing
what I want to do is I want to conquer
the world because of what use is that
realm if there's nobody to go there
right like all their souls belong to me
and so what he's doing is literally
spreading this kind of demonic plague
throughout the entirety of the United
States with a sight set on the rest of
the world starting at people in the
political level and so on and so forth
working its way down from there and the
reason why is because as with people who
have positions of power they create laws
they decide moral compasses and so on so
if they create this circumstance where
it's just kind of do whatever you want
to there's no limits right just have fun
and engage in whatever actions you want
to people will bend to their base
desires and that will lead to them
becoming sinful so that's why people
like Cardinals are being targeted and so
on and so forth it's one of the things
to keep in mind about Marvel is that
there isn't really a judeo-christian
philosophy here you find that in DC
there isn't really like a Jesus who's
watching all this stuff I mean
technically Jesus does exist but there
is not really a Jesus watching all this
stuff and it's like Harker to last let's
get involved because this is a problem
right like that doesn't really exist
there but it's one of those cool things
where even those individuals who
wouldn't normally partake in this would
be infected by a demonic presence
because what's happening is that some of
these Farmers out there for example are
kidnapping people chopping them up and
then feeding them to their pigs and
their pigs in turn are being slaughtered
and then fed to people to say nothing of
the human remains that are being ground
up and being fed to people as well it's
pretty gruesome it's pretty dark but
it's also an incredibly efficient way to
come out on top and so referencing back
to Zeb and the Council of night
magicians while they are still
incredibly ambiguous we know they do
stand against Blackhearts We don't know
if they really Ally themselves with
Johnny Blaze per se but this is enough
of a concern that they ultimately get
involved now Zeb is able to challenge
Blackheart to a degree but this guy's
power is immense he's not an easily
defeatable foe is he as powerful as
Mephisto no not a chance but he is still
incredibly capable in his own right so
the best that Zeb can really do here is
keep this guy at Bay right hold this guy
off until such a time that the Ghost
Rider can sense the presence of
Blackheart arrive on the scene and then
effectively send them back to hell and
that's exactly what happens that what
takes place here is that with Talia
Warroad having been attacked by exhaust
she's overtaken by him for a moment kind
of turned into a servant of sorts Johnny
Blaze to not put to find a point on it
is able to basically use the power of
friendship to bring her back and I'm not
even joking that's really what this is
he's like you're my partner you're my
friend and then she snaps back to normal
and then they're able to overcome
exhaustion and that's kind of it so one
of the weak points in the story that I'm
not overly fond of but it does allow
them the time they need for the Ghost
Rider to sense the presence of
Blackheart through the assistance of Zeb
and then ride onto the scene now the
funny thing about this and this is one
of the things a lot of people get wrong
when it comes to Ghost Rider is they
usually expect this kind of like great
big huge massive fight between Ghost
Rider and some kind of like demonic
entity and that has happened it has been
cool when it did happen but it doesn't
happen often in the case of Blackheart
there's no need for all that literally
the Ghost Rider shows up here and it's
just like game over right like dunzo and
basically opens a portal to hell and
sends them back and that's effectively
it now it's easy to scoff at that and
it's easy to see that as you just what's
basically a giant waste but it's not
because if you see it for what it is it
shows you how powerful the Ghost Rider
is right that for the most part barring
someone like Mephisto and even then it's
still possible there aren't very many
people that can withstand the power of
the Ghost Rider and this is him just
teleporting a guy back to hell just
saying nothing of the Penance there
which has been used on Cosmic entities
like Galactus I believe headcanon so
don't take that as an absolute truth but
I want to say that's happened right but
it's just that thing where his character
is just on a whole new level and so
where it looks like the day is
effectively saved this is where we get
to the portion where I tell you that we
end up getting the most powerful Ghost
Rider to ever exist because what happens
is behind the scenes and all of this we
transition to what's basically a kind of
experiment that's being conducted out
there by these folks influenced by this
demonic presence and what they're doing
is they're trying to harness demonic
energy specifically the power of the
Ghost Rider and the way they're doing
this is they have a test subject named
Danny catch now for anybody who knows
anything about the Ghost Rider Mythos
they'll tell you right now man when you
think of Ghost Rider you're not thinking
of Johnny Blaze you're thinking of Danny
catch and this guy is on a whole nother
level of overpowered I mean this guy is
nuts this guy's healing factor is next
level this guy's pinned stairs Next
Level this guy in a reasonable comic
this guy would dominate Johnny Blaze and
it wouldn't even be funny with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end make sure you guys click this
link so you can get caught up on all the
Ghost Rider videos we've done so far and
I will catch
peace